do you consider yourself a journalist no
okay
what do you under this sir I do not
appreciate the sarcasm question of the
day
where were you when you realized that
journalism wasn't what you thought it
was it was probably me with Dan Rather
forging documents that was one and now
we're talking about fake news Walt when
Walter Cronkite said I believe the quote
was you can't be a reporter and not be
somewhat of a liberal I remember that
hit me like a just a blast of cold water
because we're about to show you an
unedited interview with the writer of an
article at the Austin Chronicle I
think's Fenn computer has this as an
overlay it was an article written about
the recent Crowder confronts yep about
the video never featured the video just
just now riddled with an accuracies to
feature yes
so we tried to reach this girl and we
weren't able to reach the the author and
then she called us back so that's what
you're about to you hazing it's not
about the Austin Chronicle right I mean
I get it not many people read it what
it's about is the media at large this
has been going on I've encountered this
with daily beast with Washington Post
with Sky News you were there when we did
this was with Sky News you know it's
about the media getting away with this
scot-free for so long and we just can't
it's kind of like the crowd it confronts
we just can't allow it to continue so
hope you enjoy the phone call steven
crowder hi this is Jesse Kate hey Jesse
how are you I'm well how are you I'm
doing well I'm glad we were able to
connect finally absolutely thanks for
reaching out sure well I know the first
thing is I know you were looking for
someone to to comment from from my side
here on this story I had some questions
for you curious is to you you wrote an
article about a video exclusively kind
of a play-by-play but never included the
video what's that sure well you know
it's pretty easy to find I did include
the title and mention the platform
YouTube that it's on so anyone who can
use the Internet can find that but I do
have some questions for you actually
after but why wouldn't you embed it down
at that I don't understand because of
some of the inaccuracies I'd like to go
over or clearly stated in the video or
at least featured in the video so is
there a reason you didn't embed it well
I just specifically said that we chose
not to do that but I did include the
title and
platform that it's on so that's my
answer so if you would like to tell me
about the inaccuracies that you found
I'm just happy to hear you out and I'd
love to hear those absolutely well first
off I'm glad were finally speaking
because the first inaccuracy I mean you
didn't reach out to me at all directly
for a for a comment or for my side of
the story which surprised me considering
this is reporting well I did reach out
to see our TV and I put that in there I
have the email thread and I'm happy to
provide you with that sure well I know
you reached out to a generic page and
see our TV that you know I don't work
for them we have a partnership agreement
and you were advocated to go to my
social media pages of all my producers
their emails are there with a very quick
simple contact me page and I know you
wrote that you were not about to quote
fall into that trap what
so what trap is that well I'm not going
to use my personal social media platform
to reach out from this on this story so
I'm calling you now from my cell phone
number so that's that's as personal as
I'm willing to get on this as a
journalist I would just like to
streamline this conversation and get the
inaccuracies that you measure well
that's an act okay I'm happy to hear you
out now sure well that's right there
that's that's one inaccuracy that the
implication that you had reached out to
me because we never received word now of
course would have loved to give our side
especially if we would have known that
you weren't going to feature the video
that was in question you know a couple
of things forget to the other
inaccuracies which are which are more
obvious and you mentioned our fans doxed
this person they received death threats
any evidence of that well it's all over
the comment threads I was able to find
those people that the person that Julian
and the persons manager all of their
personal information is on multiple
platforms at this point sure so I guess
we needed to find first as you mentioned
journalistic integrity I know that's
important well what do you what do you
mean when you say daxing I want to make
sure I'm not miss construed this well
the release of someone's public and
formal information to the public their
home address in this particular case the
employee to my knowledge is
transgender both their birth name and
the name that they go by we're released
which is can be very dangerous the all
sorts of personal information is out
there now about about these individuals
which I'm sure you know I understand
from the little that I have been able to
find you know in terms of your beliefs
on these types of things that you
certainly don't advocate for violence
and I didn't know for stories it yeah
absolutely which I am very happy to hear
that yeah well I don't know that you did
mention it actually hell I don't know
that you did that's another thing I
don't know that you did mention that you
know you talked about me being six to
and the person being smaller I find out
that you went out of your way to to
mention that information but not that I
repeatedly said I am not calling any
actions to violence I would never want
violence against against you I I didn't
see that in there and that was in the
video sure I understand that I also I
mean you are 62 is that an accurate but
why would why would you list my my tale
of the tape and not my actions where I
clearly stated listen
no violence why doesn't that make the
peace but my science does well because
it's an act of aggression to go behind
the counter okay so you don't so you
think that act is more significant than
me saying I am not advocating violence
at all please just take the post down
and this will be the end of it you think
me being six to and larger is more
important than my active calls to action
which are non-violence I certainly am
NOT qualifying that or ranking them okay
mentioned at all at all I'm sorry you
didn't mention one at all okay well the
thing is here is I'm not calling you to
be interrogated I'm asking you to I'm
giving you an opportunity sure right
wrong fine I'm trying to I'm trying to
no one reached out to us for comment you
mentioned my size you don't mention that
I clearly and explicitly in repeatedly
state calls to non-violence you imply
that we Doc's them or or that our fans
did do you know who released the
information of where the juice land was
in the personal information you know who
did that right why don't you tell me you
okay in the very first paragraph of your
article you're the one who states the
MLK juice land and releases us in from
not us we blurred the name we never
mention location you did it
I also did not release that person's
name okay so if you really need neither
did we but you're the one who released
the location and the information you
understand to to imply that something to
our fans that you did it okay I
appreciate you saying that I find that
to be inaccurate but can we please move
on to the other things that you I'm very
curious about the other inaccuracies
that you said your your voicemail to me
quote said it was riddled yes well
there's three there's three and right
now you just said here's the thing if I
say it's in your article you can bring
it up right now
you mentioned where the juice land is
that's you and you say I don't believe
that's accurate
this can't be a fruitful discussion okay
another thing you mentioned alright
comedian a quick rudimentary Google
search would show you that I'm not
alright I've very fervently disavowed
the alt right and as a matter of fact
they've attacked me so can we agree that
that's another at least one inaccuracy
where's the due diligence there I don't
find that to be an inaccuracy but I why
not why not well there are various
reasons but it seems like we're arguing
semantics name one and name one no
semantics name one I say I'm not all
right
I've disavowed them hey you're raising
your voice at me I am not raising my
voice answer responding to you and it
okay I'm not raising my voice thank you
I'd appreciate it if we could just keep
this very civil I absolutely why am i
all right
other than excuse me can can I please
finish my statement you've interrupted
everything that I have to say I would
appreciate keeping this civil okay
please do not raise your voice at me
moving on why am i all right I am I'm
trying to tell you okay um I would you
like to go on or should I please thank
you I appreciate that you do not like
that term that is an umbrella term and
I'm not the only person who uses it I
understand that you do not identify as
and so I'm happy to update the story
with the proper nomenclature that you
would like me to use what is that sir
I'm just a conservative but it's not
about me it's not about me I mean I know
you you choose to use the pronoun about
you know it's not about how I identify I
am NOT alt-right that's not a matter of
editorial ization it's just wrong in
your opinion no are we talking about
reporting here accurate reporting why
would if for example if someone else
were to say I am NOT a Democrat nor have
I ever been a Democrat
I cannot stand Democrats and they were
attacked by Democrats on the record and
then you wrote about them as a Democrat
and they said hey you need to correct
this I'm not a Democrat and you said in
your opinion did can we agree that's
that's that's not correct that's that's
borderline journalistic malpractice if
you're gonna say that that's not
editorialize ation if you want to say
this as an opinion piece fine but it's
not factual
well Democrat and Republican are
recognized in a legal sense all right is
not a descriptor okay so that's how we
get around it but would you say it's at
least at the very least a rudimentary
Google search would would help
considering I've been one of the most
active people at the forefront of not
involving myself with the alt right well
I guess perhaps maybe we could just
discuss what your what your issues with
the alt right are that make you want to
be so far away from them that you're
willing to have sure yeah well I'm just
because I know sure well I know you
mentioned as a catch-all term and I know
that people at your paper have used it
to refer to people under a catch-all
umbrella including National Socialists
which I'm not I'm not a nationalist I am
not under the implicit I know the
implications that I'm a racist I'm not
that I just haven't really identified as
alt right ever I've clearly explicitly
listed my values I'm a traditionalist
constitutionalist conservative you can
call me a federalist but again I think
you know why you use the term all right
you mentioned you didn't find the
original post
I found that curious the original you
mean the original Facebook posts that we
included in our video is you weren't
able to find those I absolutely found
yours but I could not find the other
ones because that person has deleted all
of their social media accounts okay so
you know but you can find those I know
you did also again in the
video this is why showing the video when
an article the play-by-play of a video
is so important this person had made it
on camera to posting those in the video
that's not mentioned I watched the video
okay would you would you be willing to
send me the information that you have
the comments the screenshots those
things to my email address I would love
to see the originals that you posted in
the video sure absolutely I just the
person in the video in question Cameron
says that they are his/her posts okay
should that be included it's up to you
would you like me to include that but
what's the implication if you say I
wasn't able to find the original post
and never mention and never show the
video never mentioned that in the video
this person in question says yeah yeah
of course those are my posts is that not
relevant okay I suppose that it is I'm
happy to quote you a saying that you
believe that it's relevant would you
like me did you well I absolutely more
than happy to have you quote me on that
but I would look for it if you quote
this person in the video saying those
are absolutely my posts shall I send a
timecode what should you send to what
I'm sorry the phone cut out shall I send
a a timecode a timestamp to the video
where this statement is made i watch the
video I'm aware okay so why didn't you
include it I did not include the video
i've already know why did you not
include this person saying that these
are my posts your article leaves it to
imagination as though we made up posts
as though you couldn't find them as
though there's no evidence the evidence
is in admission and screenshots the
person admits in the video that is
relevant information if we're going to
be practicing journalism is it not sure
again I did include the quotes did I not
the quotes article right now the person
saying those are my posts it says
according to screenshots posted by the
Crowder camp in a YouTube video and it
goes on which I specifically mentioned
there that I've rejected that name so no
back to your
earlier statement that I released that
information I have rejected that
person's name but anyway I just just to
be clear what is redacted mean removed
the name for safety purposes is which I
write so clearly stated in the article
yes and remove now yeah which I
appreciate I actually do that you
blurred out the name just on your video
sure but again all of that I realize you
cannot you know control what your
commenters do I understand that
completely
neither can I sure we'll notice on our
on our article I mean clearly there's
nothing you can do about commenters I
understand that right but no and I
appreciate that listen I know you would
not advocate violence nor would you
would you
tasin approve of someone you know
actively posting a plot to slash tires
or was someone else you notice
firebombing the van these these go on
for a long time but it does involve in
these people again it goes back to you
do not include the quote where this
person said that they were this person's
post on Facebook so no that is not
included in there and when you say I
couldn't find the original posts talk
about how I'm six-two and not my active
call to non-violence this is an
inaccurate piece it's riddled with
inaccuracies like we said we've been
through four or five now and I not in
control my fans but I am not judging you
for anything your fans have said I am
calling your attention to things you've
said I understand and my actual
statement is we have yet to obtain the
original post and the employee social
media account appears to be deleted from
what we can gather online the following
is the basic rundown yes so would you
not deem it relevant that the person
gathering online is in the video the
person in question said these are my
posts of course these are my posts is
that not relevant I suppose and I
suppose what it is and I'm happy to
quote you on that is that yes don't
quote me quote them on it you said
you've seen the video quote them on it
them saying
of course those are my posts I don't
need you to quote me this person said it
it's on camera is that Inquirer are we
disap are you disagreeing with me on
that I'm confused here clear I never
said that I disagreed with you so then
why is it not pardon in my mouth so then
what is it what is the issue here don't
quote me quote the person in question
who said of course this is my post
otherwise its activism not journalism
excuse me otherwise it is activism not
journalism okay do you consider yourself
a journalist no okay
what do you under this sir I do not
appreciate the sarcasm
no do you of course I am
okay well I'm it was not sarcastic at
all I wasn't quite sure from this
conversation I thought maybe you were
not beds person which is totally fine I
have no problem with someone who is an
op-ed writer who's an opinion writer I
have nope no problem that if it's
clearly explicitly stated in the piece I
understand that going back to it you are
upset that I mentioned your height but
it's the entire excuse me no okay well
could I finish please I understand that
you have mentioned that I mentioned your
height multiple times so the reason that
I did that which I'm pretty sure reads
very clearly that the reason that that
is relevant is because you did walk
behind the counter of a business yes is
that is that a typical behavior of you I
mean is that is that how you choose to
confront people I know that the
confronting people is kind of your kind
of your thing no it's not no it's not
actually it's not as a matter of fact
there there are over 30 million plays
unchanged my mind segments the reason
this segment has started by the way we
were there in Austin we spoke with I
came over her name Danielle she's a
transgender woman running for City
Council male to female transgender this
went on while there were calls to
firebomb our van this occurred while
this person was advocating and plotting
to slash our tires what we were actually
sitting down doing it change my mind
segment
which is a completely unedited interview
where we sit on the street and allow
anyone to have a conversation so it's
not kind of my thing there are two of
these I think there are 10 plus of those
and this is just when people advocate
violence no it's not my thing
this person's thing is advocating
violence my issue here is not that you
list my height the issue here is that
you write an article or you say you
couldn't find the original post you
never quote the person in question who
openly says of course those are my posts
you do not show the video you refer to
me as all you refer I'm just gonna
finish here you refer to me as alt right
you mentioned my height and not my
active call to non-violence again I
state this is a piece very selectively
choosing facts if we want to call it
those and it's activism not journalism
and I would just appreciate if it's
labeled such I don't care if you less my
height if you say six-foot-two steven
crowder glistening in the Sun walked
behind the kitchen and said hey hey just
to be clear I would never advocate
violence against you I wouldn't have a
problem with it if you were to say that
we couldn't find the post because they
were deleted but in the video openly
says of course those are my posts that
changes context because if people
understand that this of course was the
person in question plotting to slash
tires
talking about making sure that I don't
expose myself or em ever vulnerable
again and they understand that I'm
simply asking this person in the video
to remove it and that would be the end I
think that changes the context of the
piece would you not agree I understand
where you're coming from but to clear up
the inaccuracies that you just mentioned
I did quote that person three times
three times saying of course that is my
post the fact that I did not include
that one statement does not verify the
accuracy of the statement it is pivotal
of course it listen you can quote them
talk you can quote them saying Steven
Crowder's mean all you want that's
completely could not be less relevant
not that is not did you read the thing I
have it right in front of me no where is
it included and zero places that that
statement is not but three statements in
a row are including the one in which
this person said that he
whereas it is I would just remove the
signs and flashes tires that's the part
you had an issue with there was also a
part that I included in which that
person said I worked with some on the
robert e lee statue i included that as
well so the idea that I was just falsely
portraying this person as being
completely innocent is completely
off-base you falsely portrayed the
accuracy of what we had posted saying
you could not find it and you did not
include the video nor the quote from the
video where this person confirms that it
was indeed them I think that's pretty
important it doesn't matter if you say
steven crowder said this happened but I
wasn't able to confirm any of it when
you don't post the video and you don't
post the quote from said video of the
person saying of course that's me so now
you see why the video is kind of kind of
key here and it's curious that you
didn't include it because at least
people could watch it for themselves and
go oh of course this transgender person
that juice lens said that's me those are
my posts well that puts it to bed sir
I've gone over this multiple times what
I would also like you to do is answer my
question about whether or not you feel
that it was an act of aggression to go
behind the counter and hover over that
person within one foot of his face is
that an act of aggression no you don't
believe that it is I do not believe that
it is when I walk back and say just to
be clear I am not advocating violence I
would like you to remove an active call
to violence against me
and that'll be the end of it and the
person says no I'm not gonna remove my
post I don't believe so
I don't but i but i but i am i am
totally for i am totally fine
with showing all of the video all of the
gather whatever you can i think this
person might have some more footage for
you we said we've said anyone who has
any footage from it please send it in I
am very comfortable with allowing people
to see all of it as much context as
possible and making their own decisions
i I understand that
why do you not feel that that is an act
of aggression to go behind the counter
of someone's workplace and stand within
one foot of their face I just answered
why do you not think it to be
journalistic malpractice when you do not
quote someone admitting to a crime on
camera sir you have yet to answer
Michael
I just did so I'm gonna answer it again
no I do not now let me explain it why
again I said I do not and the reason why
is when I walk back there and say openly
explicitly not calling any actions to
violence I don't want any violence to
come to you
please take this down know what I'm okay
with if someone wants to interpret it
that way because they've watched the
video and they've seen the person admit
to the crime I'm fine with someone
having that opinion what I'm not okay
with is a journalist going out there
selectively writing an article omitting
facts omitting key details as to
confirmation of the authenticity of
these acts and allowing along this to
passes journalism that's what have a
problem with I'm fine with anyone having
any opinion of me that they want so long
as it's based on accuracy your piece
isn't in your opinion I also have no
coin on my opinion on my opinion I have
one question about the update that I
posted at the end of the article from
APD Austin Police Department but there's
two case numbers associated yep one is
criminal mischief and the other is
criminal trespass to my knowledge the
criminal trespass is the based on the
report that juice land employees filed
against you and your team has there been
any update on that and do you consider
that be trespassing well there is there
is no update on the police said as long
as they don't go back in a year it's
fine it was a notice the other one is
ongoing and it's been passed down to a
detective because there's a much more
serious criminal activity I'd be happy
to send you the Austin PD if you'd like
the report yes I'd be happy to direct
you to them they were pretty clear that
one's a notice don't just don't come
back that's not a crook that's not a
crime don't come back within a year then
it would be trespassing one is an
ongoing investigation because of some
information which we actually omitted
for safety purposes there's there's more
evidence that we didn't include but
again you can DEP the detectives in the
police will be doing their due diligence
to look into the quotes and posts and
ensuring the accuracy when they're
currently doing so yes I posted that
myself so I do I am aware of that yes I
was just
giving you an opportunity to add
anything else regarding that specific
part of the story we won't do it like no
we'll find our juice elsewhere for the
next year so we were happy to just get a
warning okay and is there anything else
that you find to be inaccurate Latorre
that I find to be inaccurate the whole
store yeah the basically the whole theme
of the story the whole spirit of the
activism of the story disguises
journalism that's what you have a
problem with it's the theme I have a
problem in this area of here's what I
have a problem with do you do you really
want me to answer your question well I
wouldn't have asked you okay I just say
because I I think you might not like the
answer I'm gonna try and be as common
symbol as possible but also as honest as
possible in the air of people freaking
out about fake news when people omit
videos while writing an article
exclusively about a video omit facts
that would be key details by the way key
witnesses in a court case omit
information and also mislead the
audience with information that's
selectively edited for example reaching
out to some generic line and Sierra TV
acting as though you'd reached out to me
directly I have a problem with this
passing as news because it's not this is
not news it's activism and I know that
you get very offended when I say I think
you're an activist not a journalist but
when I say hey listen there's a quote
right in this video and you say well
that in your opinion it's not my opinion
it's like me saying right now this guy
is blue and your opinion no it's not
when I say well listen this is a police
fort you said well in your opinion it's
not my opinion when I say you know one
reached out to us directly and you say
in your opinion it's not my opinion when
I say I'm not alright and have openly
advocated against the alt-right and you
say in your opinion it's not my opinion
but all of the things have mentioned are
your opinion and for some reason you're
okay passing this off as journalism and
I think that's a disservice to your
readers that's what I have a problem
with and I like I said I appreciate you
taking the time but I would hope that
both of us have some some things to
think about after this conversation you
agree that you do have things to think
about after this conversation
solutely could you tell me what some of
those are no those are my private
thoughts but I just I just gave you I
just gave you quite a bit if you'd like
to talk another time or even listen to
have you on the show to discuss that
we'd be more than happy to we do that
all the time with people who disagree
with us again it's not about confronting
it's very rare when there are calls to
violence that's when we confront but we
have people all the time on the show
with differing opinions we're willing to
hear anyone and everyone mmm I think
it's actually probably the one and only
example online where we do that
consistently and respectfully so only
example online you and your team are the
only example online of people doing that
yes of people hosting differing opinions
completely unedited in long-form
interviews consistently and respectfully
yeah I would say so I would say they're
very few maybe a couple other on the
right-wing but certainly not on the left
yeah and and not not alright to be
cannot to be confused with the
right-wing not the alright that's what
you're saying
did you hear me say alright I I'm just
double-checking since apparently that
term is a point of contention for you
it's not the term it's a point of
contention
it's haoles you are as a journalist that
you didn't do a rudimentary search you
could type an alt right steven crowder
and find very very quickly my stance
it's not it's not it's not about the
term it's about the journalistic
laziness okay is there anything else no
I think that's good I I appreciate I
would welcome you on the show we have to
go tape one here right now but I I
appreciate you taking the time and you
have anything any other questions for me
I don't and if I do I can I reach you
through this number best bet is probably
an email actually this number isn't
isn't always readily available and
someone isn't necessarily by the
landline so yeah I know an email would
be great
appreciate it and at your I just one
last thing you're aware that Texas is a
single party consent state correct what
it what are you asking me thank you very
much appreciate it
[Music]
and there you have it journalism today
in 2018 your thoughts I'm curious
subscribe watch one of these other
videos or hit the notification Bell well
you should hit that if you subscribe
anyways because subscriptions don't mean
anything on you to anymore now you have
to get notifications and it shows up in
your inbox so I don't know why you
subscribe in the first place but that's
what you have to do also making money
off these videos anymore because YouTube
decided why they just said we're not
going to and when we said why they
didn't tell us why exactly imagine if
you showed up to your job daily work and
then they said hey by the way we're not
gonna pay you said why they said piss
off